foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
sorry
I'm Wade I'm Amber
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right that's the car
oh my God okay
not sure if you knew who I am but I'm
about to rule the world wow
yay but there's one problem there's a
human has a mustache just like you
do you think I know every human being
with a mustache wearing a magnetical
outfit with a hat with the letter of his
first name on it because I don't
Bowser is coming
together we
are going to stop that monster how look
at us we're able
oh I got this no problem
our big adventure begins now ah get
enough get it up get it off
there's a huge Universe out there
there's a lot of galaxies
they're all counting on us
her
o
[Music]
foreign
I can hear you being quiet mom
I am
hope I didn't ice your game man
no one my age says those words in that
order
it's just hard to see my little man not
be my little boy all the time
yeah
for years I've been taking care of this
little boy
foreign
[Music]
that he feels like he belongs wherever
he wants to be
he wants to go out into the world and do
great big things
not bad kid
and what I worry about most
I love you moms
yes they won't look out for you like us
miles
wanna get out of here
wherever you go from here you have to
promise to take care of that little boy
for me
make sure he never forgets where he came
from
[Music]
and he never doubts that he's loved
and he never lets anyone
tell him that he doesn't belong there
you gotta promise miles
I promise
[Music]
who do you think you are really
we are supposed to be the good guys we
are
[Music]
beneath the world of the living lies the
land of the living dead today my
daughter the Phoenix will choose your
future husband
in seven days you shall wet the princess
marry we've never even met him I have to
marry a guy whose only Talent is riding
around in a circle if anything happens
to this ring they will cut out your
tongue and pluck out your eyes kind of
brings new meaning to the expression
Love is Blind
this ring is going
where nobody else can get to him
[Music]
on the other side of this door
like a door
would you look at that a royal wedding
ring
no where's the ring
this could only be the work of livings
this will be the jewel of my new
exhibition the only way to get it back
is to go to the world of the living
you're not alone you have a team
what ice is this I've never seen
anything like it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the original fairy tales are all the
same
the princess the hero but this story
is all about me meow
our next Target is this way okay what
have you noticed there's no food that is
odd for a market tell
it smells doesn't it smells like a a
mystery
the food in the town but continues to uh
up here
for us you wanted to see us there are
new rats in town I can feel it catch
them and bring them to me yes sir
remember this is a new town There's
bound to be new tracks
I know just what we must do next solve
the mystery of our town ready
your savior has arrived hey
everyone look for the entrance to the
secret passage
Keith are you all right yeah I'm all
right because I landed on my head no
wonder we didn't see it
no I have a thing for rats it's not cool
to
culture
police follow me here I come
to me
then feel my pain
if my head fits the rest will follow
no
all right
the amazing Maurice it's really not your
average fairy tale don't worry I can't
always lands on its feet
[Music]
amazing Maurice
[Music]
I've always wanted to be a heroine
[Music]
a hero is a human Patty not a little
mouse like you oh you missed you Zeus
our gratitude it's awesome certainly
deserve
I'll give you Southern days to make a
statue of me that as beautiful as my
brothers come on they're all counting on
us
I wonder what it's like going through
rough weather on a boat add more
lightning
feeling a bit seasick don't have my
ceilings yet
[Music]
you're a family and we can conquer
anything
is
super fun
um
[Music]
where
[Music]
yes sir
hello
[Music]
[Music]
Legion Academy if you wanted you could
train here think of them as the Futures
Justice League
it is so great to meet you I'm monel
this is the rest of the academy trainees
we are the front lines administering
Justice and preventing War
her powers Brainiac
I am not going to let you hurt anyone
else with her abilities that makes her a
threat I don't like what you're implying
no idea where the rest of the Legion is
I've seen the dark circle come on we
don't have very much time it's up to us
so let's go be heroes
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
users of Heidi
hurry hop on
[Music]
are you awake
at least all the best-selling novels
what if he can't find us he'll find us
just wait a bit no Shenanigans makes for
a terrible day
[Music]
welcome
[Music]
where do you want I have brought a gift
how about we try and make a barter
can you peel potatoes
Casper and cephalt cannot be found
anywhere
naturally Mr plots and hearts what did
you call me Mr loves and plots cut Grace
Hudson plots Mr [ __ ] and nuts
catch a robber
oh artist you whippersnappers it takes
magic what is this hand very weird
courage
entry all sorts of extremely forbidden
well maybe I'll come back tomorrow and
friends yet I am glad to see you yeah me
too
pots and thoughts let's check this up
[Music]
per Hutt
coming soon
nice gentlemen about the bait is a
musical Talent Discovery show each week
we coach a musical act if the winner
will get a Mega deal recordings contract
I was asked to be the next coach on
Battle the beat I'll teach these kids
how to be the Rock God
Rock sensation
and you will be coaching the all-girl
group canine what
from the award-winning team behind
Clifford the Big Red Dog they don't know
anything about rock and roll rock and
roll isn't the only kind of music wow
does anyone know the water
ladies you want to win the recording
contract don't you yeah let's rock and
roll
[Music]
[Applause]
let's hear from our esteemed coaches
they sounded a little pitchy to me and I
would love to agree with you neon but
then we would both be wrong
[Applause]
you are the new face of the show the
king of Zing I gotta take this he's
always gone now I'm the king of Zayn
you look like that dude that sells
mattresses on late night TV
when you lose your way aren't you
supposed to be coaching your performers
is this how you want everyone to act
come together can I be honest yes unless
it's gonna upset me lies will do fine
it's a music show that's not really
about the music there is no music
without Harmony so we should be working
together
in Harmony and rock the world with music
you have the power to bring everyone
together
Rock
dog 3 Battle the beat
[Music]
good